[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous donnons encore s'offrent un deck du
mal aux hawks mais avant le goal de tnt
du moment le plus gênant d'assurer ce
jeune chroniqueur date été primés mais
qui a failli perdre son job en direct au
moment des remerciements ça s'est joué à
une seconde observez bien on voit très
bien moment il se dit dans sa tête houla
faut que j'y retourne pas ce qu'est ma
place en jeu que voilà merci à tous et
je suis très content merci beaucoup
non maintenant tu vas perdre ton job mec
revient revient celle ci
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je vous laisserai jamais non
plus je vous le dis et au pire des cas
si on vous lâche
vous irez chez dorée voilà
arrêté